[Music]
so
[Music]
oh i
posted a video this morning youtube
[ __ ] me right in the butthole wait
what did it do oh it's it's bottom
10 out of 10. yeah that's the one
i don't even know what to do anymore
we got to switch to tick-tock
[Music]
are we are we just behind yeah i don't
know you know i don't know if it's uh
i just i don't know what gets the
algorithm wet
i don't know if it's because i've had
too many uh
no no badges you know oh no no d
monetized no no sometimes i'm like man
it's maybe not the algorithm it's just
like people don't
aren't into my videos anymore yeah and
that's fine you know
yeah that's why you got to keep like
iterating
you know yeah no i have some ideas but
it is kind of a little bit demoralizing
fully acknowledge that yeah
because i think it's like all the [ __ ]
that i love to do i just know it's just
a bit more niche and it just doesn't
work
you know
if i want to do like some obscure sketch
that's a commentary on like digital
experience yeah that's that's just not
gonna beat out [ __ ] we put five
people in a circle and we're gonna watch
them stand here like all right yeah
what i did yesterday that is potentially
the best like director concept i think
i've had yet nice really went well yeah
yeah troy cutting it he is
um i made a music video guys
a bunch of cows it's a bunch of cows
standing in a row yeah
yeah one by one
yeah
it's a commentary on uh ice cream
and at the end it says got milk yeah
it's literally it's a gut milk or a fist
cause no but i just felt as we were
doing it i felt like yeah this is the
[ __ ] i really understand it was the
first time where i wasn't stressed out
because i actually felt that i
understand what is achievable in a
certain setup in a certain time frame
like what you can actually do with the
camera but yeah it's all black and white
and i'm pissed because i have it it's i
have messages weeks before kanye's video
came out he [ __ ] puts out his black
and white [ __ ]
they're functionally very different so i
but i made that and i'm like this is
what i feel like i'm actually good at
and like performing live i think i'm
actually good at but like youtube i just
don't think it captures like what i'm
the best at yeah so
yeah i think my views have been going
down because it's just kind of like
people are like what are we doing here
yeah
we know you don't love it we don't
really love it so what are you doing
here yeah honestly i really like working
on this on tmg studios just in general
yeah same you know that really excites
me now and i think it just kind of kind
of like takes my focus away from youtube
a little bit as i'm sure you probably
feel with stand up and with music and
although i did i made a song for my
video that i posted yesterday and i
produced the whole thing from scratch
engineered the whole thing and that like
really i had so much fun doing and
you're making something yeah well it's
just like i don't know it's just like it
felt good to like actually give a [ __ ]
again about about my video about my
videos yeah yeah i don't know i
i was like debating just debating the
baby i was debating i was debating let's
go hold up yeah i debated taking all my
brand money and then just like
i think i have like i don't know like 10
or 12 songs just in the can no it's like
all different ideas because really what
i want to do i just want to direct [ __ ]
again okay i like it picasso so i'm just
going to use it as like a medium to like
expand my director portfolio um
i don't know we've always we've kicked
around the idea of a feature obviously i
have a few ideas on that we should
definitely do that yeah i have a short i
i wrote and like i'm just thinking maybe
this year i just like go back to that
yeah just bail on [ __ ] uh
look at these bad tech talks
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah i don't know youtube my bad i kid
cudi dude
well that's interesting
is it dude
oh no it's interesting our failing
youtube channels are interesting to you
they're not really failing
no kidding i'm really failing i'm
i'm kidding it's like a dip in the road
i was telling you the other day like i
think maybe like this is good like when
[ __ ] like this happens it forces you to
like oh it wakes you up a little bit
yeah yeah yeah exactly makes you it's
like ah you're getting comfortable yeah
it's that and you you know like when
people have been entertained in
entertainment and entertainment
for a long time they always have like
these weird speeches where they're like
yeah i went through this phase and like
you know i just wasn't sure what i
wanted to do and you're like shut the
[ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ] up like but that's it's
just one of those yeah yeah i mean like
that's why i really like what we do here
and that's why i'm really grateful that
we put in the time like a while ago to
start doing all these different sort of
things yeah so that when one of them
isn't really stimulating that part of
your brain anymore then you can still
come here today and set up the [ __ ]
nuts kicking machine yeah and feel
[ __ ] excited yeah when we used to do
that's cringe and stuff like i would
[ __ ] be on cloud nine yeah when you
came over and we would sit down and bang
one of those out and i just knew it was
gonna be a crazy hit and that we were
like pushing the boundary on on what is
like acceptable like viral content on
youtube sure or just something unique
and it just felt like we were onto
something new yeah that like really
really made me feel
incredible and then when we started
doing music and people were like i don't
get this what is this it's so good but
yeah yeah that made me feel really
excited yeah and now that we can come
here and and do new shows that makes me
feel really excited
so i'm happy that we always have those
things that we can still push ourselves
and yeah and evolve yeah i just think we
have a very um it's a good problem it's
a problem i'm thankful for a lot of
people have seen us attempt humor for a
long time so maybe it's just that we
have to change some of that up and
that's okay like we've entertained a lot
of people for a long time which is cool
i think it's just a lot a lot of shit's
just becoming more niche the addison
rays and stuff and like the people even
the jake pauls and [ __ ] like they hit
those like big ass numbers even they
struggle with this [ __ ] now yeah but i
mean like and i i don't mean to praise
him or anything but those
cyber bullies
those dudes know how to like evolve and
oh sure yeah like when his youtube
started going downhill he's like okay
i'm gonna become a boxer now like they
obviously also have that sort of like
okay i need to keep going and keep
changing yeah yeah yeah just get bored
and stagnant i guess what my what i'm
trying to say is even those people who
seem sort of like invincible to an
algorithm like they have the same issues
like but they just choose to do the next
exaggerated thing yeah yeah versus like
trying to maybe evolve the thing that
they're known for yeah i don't i don't
even want to come across like
complaining it's just like
observation
it's really dope every time you make
something and you're like all right this
little machine is going to rank it out
of 10. i know love that feeling i know
it's going to tell me exactly how good
i'm doing yep
hey bud here's how your career is going
right now you were excited yesterday
you had a really good experience
yesterday you might have even had a good
day but guess what
it's over your career it's actually over
the moment you pressed publish you
[ __ ] ended your career
but you had the chance to fix it next
week
it's just it's just that over and over
and over so whatever man